so I think we're ready to get started I
guess I just want to welcome everybody
to this session on cars computing and
the future of work and this is a
collaboration between Microsoft and our
u-dub team which actually includes more
than the u-dub it includes Harvard
Wellesley University of New Hampshire as
well as the University of
wisconsin-madison and we'll be
introducing everybody in a second I'm
going to actually have Edie give some
logistics first and then me and Eric
will get started on the program
excellent well thank you all very much
for coming today we're extremely excited
to have you here we have a great program
with lots of new research slides video
everything but the most important part
of today is going to be the discussion
and collaboration that we have so we're
very excited to have you working on the
papers on your tables we're gonna be
brainstorming together and we're
fortunate to have some good friends from
urban wild studios who are gonna do
graphic note-taking throughout the day
so this is going to be very dynamic we
will ask because we're recording it and
we have a couple collaborators on the
phone if you have questions we'll bring
you a mic and I think it's gonna be a
wonderful day you know where the coffee
is so please caffeinate accordingly and
I think we'll just get started okay
great thank you very much ed okay so
just want to give everybody just
overview of what the agenda is so we're
gonna start off in the morning with just
welcomes and introductions so we'll
we'll do all introductions about
everybody in just a second
we're gonna have an overview of four
topics basically on ongoing projects
this is going to include Shamsi and Eric
Andrew Boren and Raphael o who is on the
phone as well as Satish and then what
we'd ask you to do while they're talking
so the talks are only going to be 10
minutes and I'm gonna be a major downer
by basically clocking people but what we
really want to do is make sure we open
it up for discussions for everybody so
we're gonna give you ten minutes for
discussions and what we'd like you to do
is as you're asking questions I'm
thinking about ideas you have post-its
and notepads on the table as well as
pens and what we like to do is just
write out your ideas and then as you
write up your idea
you'll see that there's actually white
papers along the board go ahead and pick
it up and stick it on there and then
John Lee is gonna be our runner for the
morning and he's gonna go around and
take a look at what those ideas are and
then try to consolidate it so that we
have a 20-minute break during that
20-minute break we're gonna actually go
through and try to get you guys into
groups for right after the break so
we're gonna put you into four groups and
basically discuss some of the topics
that we went over and then right after
that we will have you know follow up and
then lunch and then the afternoon we're
gonna do it again but instead of talking
about ongoing projects we're gonna talk
more about just theoretically like where
should the future work be in cars and
what we should be going so we'll have
four additional talks in the afternoon
and then again we're gonna ask you to do
the same exercise then we'll have a
break and then we're gonna again have
the discussions and then and then kind
of wrap up and tell you what our next
steps are so hopefully that would be
something that you'll enjoy doing so
what we'd like to do is just kind of get
to know who everybody is so we wanted to
be able to do introductions so because
many of us are academics and we tend to
talk really long I'm trying to keep you
to like something really short which is
I'm gonna ask you this number one say
what your name is what where you're from
and then in the future what you hope to
do while you're drier traveling in the
cars so for example I'll get started hi
my name is Linda Boyle I'm from the
University of Washington and in the
future I hope to be able to not be
motion sickness while I work on a lot of
stuff in my car
Eric would you like to go next and then
we'll go around the room known as
microphones which you won't get the
remote you won't get the recording
without the mic okay then I would just
be very fair my name is Vera Horvath
I am from Kirkland Washington in the
future I hope to be able to minimize
distractions and drive more safely on
all fronts and then we'll start passing
around the mic and be expedient mm-hmm
good morning my name is adorned home
from Microsoft Research and in the
future I hope to talk to my digital
assistant while I'm in the car hi I'm
Andrew Coonan from the University of New
Hampshire
and in the future I'd like to be able to
listen to audiobooks and annotate them
while I'm in the car
hi I'm Oh reach share from Wellesley
College in the future I would like to
effectively rehearse my PowerPoint
presentation as I'm going to this
workshop hi I'm Duncan Brumby
I'm from University College London and
in the future who's gonna say go for a
nap while driving hi I'm Sean said well
I'm from Microsoft research in the
future I hope to be able to capture my
thoughts while travelling in my car and
I also suffer from motion sickness so I
am Wendy Cooper
I'm with MSR and in the future I'd like
to have an intelligent conversation with
my car in my car I'm hot on salmon I'm
with the University of Maryland in the
future I like this safely goes off in my
car just as I do on the train and on the
plane hi I'm Lewis Lam from Brazil
federal University of Rio Grande and so
it's in the south of the country in the
future I hope to feel safer when I sleep
while traveling my time hello everyone
my name is Jacob check a risky I'm with
the University of Alabama actually don't
like driving I bike everywhere almost
everywhere so I hope to be able to
continue doing that in the future hi my
name is Nicola banished I'm from Ann
Arbor Michigan in the future I hope to
spend more time with my family while
traveling in the car which we do a lot
hi my name is Jesse yang I'm from the
University of Michigan Ann Arbor as well
in the future I hope to sing car okay in
my car without being asked to take over
my name is John Baum I and with
Microsoft's business development team in
the future I hope not to drive while
traveling in my car
hi my name is Meryl I'm the first T of
Washington and Emma star is an intern
and future I want to finish writing my
tight papers on the car
my name is Carlo I'm from Harvard
Medical School in the future hope if I
fall into sleep I feel safe
oh we're having like huh hi good morning
I'm Satish I'm from MSR Bangalore in
India and if any of you been in India
you know how driving there is so in the
future I'm like him I'm a biker too and
I hope people driving in cars you know
pay more respect to Vipers I'm Alice
fern I'm originally from the University
of Arizona College of Medicine but now
in Microsoft Office the future I hope to
capture my thoughts while minimally
working with it well travel in the car
good morning my name is making for
foreigner from Microsoft research in the
future I hope to be less startled by
drivers who push me off the road or cut
off or scare me in other many ways while
traveling in my car my name is Jim ping
Coleman I'm from Microsoft researching
outreach and in the future I'd like to
do anything but worry about traffic or
driving much like a train or a plane
sleep learn do it anything but worry
about the stress of traffic hi I'm Jen
Tian from University of Virginia so in
the future I also hope to do everything
the car but without worry about my
privacy and safety in the future I'm
John Lee from the University of
Wisconsin and I hope to practice
mindfulness as I Drive that seems to be
the recurring theme
I'm Travis Wilson I'm from Microsoft
speech and language team and I'm gonna
actually second the very boring the very
feeling thing I would like to sleep
while I'm traveling tonight there my
name is Yvonne Tasha I am from Microsoft
Research and I hope to be well in
informatin until tonight while I'm
driving down Norman from University
California San Diego
there are two futures the near future I
hope to stop the car companies and some
of the people in this room who have made
very dangerous suggestions about what
drivers should be doing while also
driving because I want to be able to
feel safe and not just from my own car
but from other cars that might hit me in
the very far future I hope for
driverless cars where there are no
controls whatsoever and so we can do
whatever we feel like doing
unfortunately I'll be dead by the time
that happens I'm Marc save Rex I'm from
the National Science Foundation and in
the Catholic University of America in
Washington DC in the future I hope to
now repetitively do a whole variety of
these tasks that people are mentioning
because I won't have to attend to the
key aspects of the driving my name is
Audrey Schmidt I'm from the University
of Munich in Germany and I hope in the
future I try less and I travel less in
the car so and while I'm in the car I
one of these days my name is Jill I'm
from the Chicago branch of urban wild
studio and I'd like to be able to look
around at the scenery while I'm driving
in my car hi my name is Leah I am from
the Portland branch of urban wild studio
and I would like to feel more refreshed
rather than drained after a long car
ride okay and last but not least we have
Raphael online Ella will be happy
relaxed and productive and not be taken
by road rage in the TOC yeah very good
excellent okay great thank you very much
everybody
so this is what our workshop goals are
we're hoping that we're gonna be able to
share some really amazing ideas and look
for challenges and opportunities where
we can actually then come together it's
try to find some solutions so that we
can work together and so our goal is to
basically identify what these potential
collaborations are and that maybe look
for opportunities where we can work on
proposals projects research grants maybe
even
autoships papers and so what we're
hoping to do later on is we're gonna
have a matchmaking exercise so that we
can kind of match you to like the right
kind of research topics as well as the
people that that can kind of move
forward with some of the topics or areas
that you'd be interested in working on
and with that I'm going to move the mic
over to Eric so that he can discuss oops
discuss some of the future of work
topics
it just says a little bit of background
but maybe three years ago we hosted
National Academy of Engineering regional
meeting in at Microsoft and that's where
I met Linda who was speaking about what
happens to people in their abilities to
to drive after they have experienced
long periods of automated cruise control
dynamic whose control and my talk was on
human AI collaboration and mix of
designs for mixes of initiative we just
thought it'd kicked off some discussions
given to interests in particular around
my early experiences with Tesla auto
pilot I'm an avid user of it and I find
out that I almost experiment too much
and if you want to read about some of my
experiences this search on Google or
being my last name and Tesla and read
about my accident in Wired magazine and
some comments about that which is very
unfortunate but I think today this and
this is just up we just put up a six
bullets here of some topics but this
shouldn't be constraining it should be
more like framing and the starting point
just some thoughts from the organizers
you want to think about what it means to
support work in mobile settings and in
advance I'd say if possible at all
Fitness importance comment of full
automation what does it mean to do work
or to think or to to even listen to
email for example in a car or have
meetings for example and this brings up
the topic very quickly of human
cognition and the availability of
cognition to do different things and if
you believe in multiple resource theory
of mind what happens when you attend to
something
while trying to drive and surprising
situations come up for example it might
seem quite safe but when you look at
tens of millions of miles of driving
even slight changes to the probabilities
of rolling the dice leads to large-scale
life-changing events and crashes and
disabling accidents that affect people
for life and changing statistics of that
based based on designs for how audio
feeds work or people checking their
device or even looking at how to control
the Eastman dashboard in the car a very
interesting and it gets into we're here
later from Shaam see it's understanding
psychology in cognitive cognitive
psychology and new studies that are
adapted to these situations that give us
insights and designs and the interaction
of design with what we understand about
human cognition on safety risks here I
want to break this out and just
highlight this because we've all all of
us in this room have been horrified
looking to our right and seeing somebody
on the highway or on surface streets
looking at a device and then we realize
that's really us because we do the same
thing and it says it so the situation is
unbearable yet we're all on the slippery
slope it seems and that slope is has
been found for several studies to be one
of the factors in the bump going up
after seeing highway fatalities in the
u.s. dipped for a number of years now
start swinging up that's been what's
been called out is yes safety is getting
better with the cars and the machine
itself and survivability of cars but
we're seeing increased number of
accidents non-fatal and fatal because of
the obvious distribution of people who
are looking at the device for some
segments during their driving time and
so the question with this is is okay so
but something we can do about designs
short of legislating in most places
there's legislation but short of
enforcing laws about not looking at
devices while traveling what can we do
if we understand the desires and
and goals and what people are you can go
in the roads today to make it better to
reduce that upswing in safety challenges
what a directions and its design and
limiting what can be done and where for
example one of the comment here but but
this is John crumb MSR and I two years
ago published three years ago the
Tripoli I published a paper where we did
we took a large-scale data set from
Minneapolis Minnesota of accidents by
time of day and a week and what
properties and where the Sun was in the
air I mean in the sky and Zenith and
azimuth and we basically showed how you
can run a risks a risk sensitive planner
to provide safe safest routes to travel
on versus the shortest or the fastest
and the idea of being able to understand
cognition and work possibilities and
designs enough to fold that with certain
kinds of roads like taking the highway
with less turns and less the best no
pedestrians for certain kinds of work
and and folding these new kinds of
technologies for for example safety men
safety maximization on roads with needs
of cognitive needs they also this is one
example of of that at Microsoft were
actually looking at this idea of card
rides as productive times for meetings
and it's not just us
large large motor companies car
companies are thinking about designing
cars even with given by somebody else as
meeting spaces we've had some
interesting reflections about the
prospect of someday when you go to
Outlook or exchange and you're going
somewhere looking at pending meeting
requirements and even pop you know
jumping on sahteen Adela's car right to
the airport this is a seat they're
available for a meeting and you can take
your own car back or be driven back but
how can we take all that time and you
smart scheduling to get people together
for conversations one of many directions
there and then thinking about on the
design side and what cars can do how do
we look at the roadmap for automation as
Don Norman said and there could be a
breakthrough and by
so it might not be dead went you know
when we have full automation but but
anybody but I'm gonna say it is tough
and I can tell you right now even when I
trust my tests of the most after some
few thousands of miles there's a major
surprise even what I thought I knew to
be relatively deterministic behavior
given road properties exactly exactly
and again back to that Wired magazine
article but so so the question is if we
have a roadmap on automation could we
even give this community give guidance
to people developing increasingly
powerful versions of automated semi
automated driving to understand given
these kinds of needs we have and courage
that I'm going to be able to work how
can we do that more safely first so as a
simple example you know I'd like to know
if I'm doing anything in the car on
autopilot or not that I'm coming up to a
safety high-risk safety point like a
like pedestrian crosswalk and I've had
some near misses even there in autopilot
it just happened to be looking the wrong
way and trusting my car and the car
doesn't know about people or or where
crosswalks but that's known by planet
you know by maps and yeah even
understanding what people have had
trouble with hot spots and finally what
does all this mean for policies and
legislation to come up with the right
sort of methods for example my turn out
that back to someone said they were
horrified seeing some of these people in
cars on automation maybe a car my car
lights up and says I'm a town I mean
this car is given by an attention
attention deficit constrained driver
stay away pedestrians can see this
crackling on the road near their
crosswalk a big pink light flashing get
out of the way cuz I'm not sure this
person's attending to the road you can
imagine other kinds of policies mixed
with design so I'll stop there just a
few ideas and we'll be hearing more
about this later yeah thank you very
much and I think I have I'm good all
right so just kind of really quickly and
they were in a get to next speaker which
are yeah next speaker which is I'm
hoping that we can create like a matrix
such as this
where we put together what collaboration
opportunities there are we just we just
made up some topics for now but we're
hoping that as the day unfolds that will
cement what certain topics might
actually be to basically look at ways
that you know we can act we can say like
you know we want to do some
collaborations we might have some data
collections we may also even have
resources that are available there may
be students that may morning work at MSR
there may be some additional data or
data collection opportunities we're
gonna hear later about a survey that
that we've been collecting information
on that we would love to get feedback
there may be some part-time appointment
and with that I'm I'm going to great Oh
turn around that's a great question so
Don Norman just asked what we're gonna
do it notes so so what's what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have each engine
put it up on the white John John's gonna
go through Johnson so what's gonna
happen is we're gonna put it up there
just like what was your numeral sorry I
know you were
mark what Mark's gonna do is see what he
did goldstar mark and Don Goldstar so
you're just gonna put it up there and
I'm glad that we have people that are
initiating already and then John's gonna
walk around and look at them so that he
can go ahead and start moving them
around so with that I'm gonna go have
Chauncey come up to give her a talk and
Eric did you want to just do a quick
introduction on shamsky's talk well we
put up this time originally we were
gonna do this together cuz II and I work
so closely on projects that kind of
booted up our deep dive into the road
simulator and that led to a set of
studies and then later on with interns
and Thompson continued for a number of
years and has been working on to this
day and the basic idea is what do we
understand about results from cognitive
psychology when it comes to memory
attention judgment the ability to do
mechanical tasks in divided attention
and dual task or triple task scenarios
there's been a rich literature in this
space we and so a starting point is
going to the literature but then we'll
actually want to put people in
simulators designs
studies that specifically address
various kinds of what you might think to
be aspirational work tasks and cars to
understand limitations and where that
might be availability that wouldn't be
so threatening I I had some experiences
again driving and visualizing where I
thought is it possible that that we know
enough about the mind that when you
visualize thinking visually that sucked
sucks away attention from your visual
attention on that and the actual live
scene and it turns out that those
questions framed with your deep dives
and I thought the results were
surprising and and maybe get into them
later in some of our early studies but
it really is shocking and surprising and
interesting to see what really happens
in the safety safe rooms of simulators
when people are trying to do two things
even would be conversation or a recall
task or even more intensive tasks and
some see turn it over to you thank you
okay so she has ten minutes and I
wouldn't like to see some of you start
picking up some of those post-its and
start working on them and if you need a
seat we have plenty of seats on this
table too so go ahead chamsy okay can
people hear me I am Sean Sabo I am a
researcher in Microsoft Research AI and
as Eric mentioned I have been working
with Eric in this field for a while I
started as a researcher back in 2008 and
Eric said that well we have this driving
simulator and would you like to work on
some attention stuff in the car and
that's amazing because I worked on
attention management in the desktop and
so it was just a cool way of moving
domains so yesterday when I was putting
these slides together I went back to
some of the old sites that we had and
this was because I felt that we needed
to start this discussion this workshop
around the topic of safety when I was
listening to listening to people give
their one one sentence desire from what
they wanted to do in their car safety
was predominant there were six people
who said that they want
to safely nap but I think that everyone
else said that I want to be safe in the
car and do X Y & Z the fact of the
matter is that driving is no longer a
single attention task and hasn't been a
single attention test for quite a while
we even if we're not doing something in
the car there are other people in the
car we are talking to them many of those
people in the car are actually not
really attention aware people if you
haven't encountered any of them my kids
are a good example that they have no
sense of when is a good moment to
interrupt when a person is driving but
there's also these devices and these
pictures are dated because I pulled this
slide from 2010 but what I did update
this morning are well yesterday is that
there hasn't been a lot of changes in
terms of the legislation and this is the
June 2019 distracted driving laws there
are no cell phone use at all for novice
drivers in 39 states and this number has
been the same since 2014 because because
I change the side I know that no cell
phone use at all for bus drivers in 20
states we have 50 so I mean there are 30
other states that are still falling
behind handhelds are banned for all
drivers in 19 states I think that change
from 14 to 19 in the past five years
note that it's handheld bang you can
still talk you can still use Bluetooth
and text messaging is banned for all
drivers and that is in 48 states that
was 44 that four more states joined in
no state bans all use of cell phone for
adult drivers when driving now keep that
in mind that means that we are still
legislation is allowing us to do things
in the car via a cell phone via
bluetooth and car companies are picking
up on this if you think about the
inveigle assistance there now coming
into the cars and the goal is not to
make us more distracted I hope but it is
with the desire that well these vehicle
assistance will help you be do things in
the car now what I haven't heard a lot
is about the safety how are they going
to make you also be safe in the car so
there are some unique things about the
car environment right and I'm going to
just go to like manual semi-auto
and then autonomous vehicles because I
think one of the lot of the things that
we're going to discuss today are going
to eventually apply the most enormous
vehicles but what we have today as the
majority is the manual car in a manual
car which is basically the cars that
regular people like I drive it's driving
is your primary task it's a continuous
attention task and sometimes we
interleave these other non driving tests
it could be fiddling with your in
vehicle control it could be talking to
someone over the phone we have Bluetooth
it could be talking to other passengers
in the car now when you have semi
autonomous vehicles that is when the
driving sometimes becomes your secondary
task because now it allows you some
cycles to get involved in other things
and I'm thinking mostly about the level
3 and level 4 cars which are mostly
driving themselves but they do require
you to take over control at times and
that means that you have to be aware of
the road situation you can't be totally
totally zoned out and then there are no
no's vehicles which is where the car
will basically become your chauffeur
driven car and you'll be going from
point A to point B so it is still not
your office it's still a limited
attention environment it's a moving
vehicle so even if we think about doing
tasks in that environment things like
motion sickness things like being in a
clustered environment all of that comes
into play so which means that we have to
think about designing Testament in a
different way so I want to quickly go
over this because I have Bill aboard on
this a bit but the reason why
non-driving has do it in a car can be
unsafe because of the improper
attentional distribution people often
underestimate that the the cognitive
resources that are required when you're
driving and you're adding an additional
task on top of this driving is a
continuous attention test you typically
don't want your nan driving tasks to be
also continuous attention because then
you're competing and then at some point
you might just deplete your cognitive
resources we also choose improper
moments to engage in secondary tasks so
if you are in a busy road with lots of
traffic around you it's not a good idea
to start something new which is not
driving and also not understanding when
to shift focus back so all of these we
saw as opportunities to think about how
can you let drivers be more safer in the
car so
and in particular keeping in mind that
non driving tasks are going to happen a
conversation even via bluetooth that is
going to still continue so how can we
make sure that we maintain the driving
safety but also allow people to continue
or complete some of these non driving
tasks remember safety is our key point
here we are just looking for
opportunities where we can allow people
to do these tasks without compromising
safety so we look at the questions
around when what and help I'll come back
to the assistance later as we go through
but as Eric mentioned our premises here
the studies that I'm going to touch upon
are going to be all simulator studies
we're not doing anything on the road in
most cases hands-free phone conversation
is the secondary test that we were
looking at in these studies and there
was only one one study where we it was a
semi of nama scenario and we looked at
typing and video captioning as that and
there the goal was to see how easily
people were able to switch back to
driving okay so and I probably wouldn't
have enough time but I will be happy to
bring this up during the discussion
section but there were four studies and
the first one which Eric had hinted that
we wanted to know when is a good time
for someone to initiate or engage in a
phone conversation and also what does
the conversation look like the second
one we wanted to see that okay so once
we have kind of like an idea what when
should be even think about engaging in a
secondary task how can the car help the
person who is engaged in one more task
on top of driving to be alert and
vigilant on the road we also wanted to
see that okay you're having a phone
conversation there's someone on the
other end can we do something or share
some information with the other person
on the other end so that they can also
help the driver be safe and the final
one is that we wanted to look at the
role of audio alerts in a semi or no
scenario where the audio alert can help
people get out of their secondary tasks
when the car is still in autonomous mode
and then start gaining awareness about
the driving scenario so very quickly we
wanted to let me go back because I do
know that we don't have time so how is
driving performance effect
by a simultaneous phone conversation and
we were looking at three types of
conversations or three types of content
one was when a person is asked to give
step-by-step road direction to someone
else when they're driving the other one
was they were asked to recall some
information and the third one is that
they just listened to a news headline
and we also wanted to see when or what
types of roads was this being impacted
by so people who are driving on super
simple roads there's no other traffic
there than they were driving on roads
where there were a lot of traffic and
third is that there is something
unexpected that happened on the road so
people have to be able to correct for
that so again I'm gonna quickly drive to
this but what we found was interesting
so Eric and I had this hypothesis is
that clearly the direction giving tasks
is going to be the most difficult one
because that's the most I mean involved
one is that you are asking someone to
give me directions from your house to
the grocery and I'm driving and so there
should be conflict in what I'm doing and
what what I'm doing in terms of driving
and what the task asked to do turned out
that people were actually breaking that
task into smaller chunks so they would
say one sentence they would pause they
would make sure they're driving properly
and they would say I'd say the second
sentence and they would just basically
microcast this whole whole conversation
in contrast with the other test which
was recalling information these were
information like when did you last put
the gas in your car or when did you go
to the grocery last people had much more
difficulty in those tests and what we we
realized that whenever you needed
sustained attention for a task that was
much more difficult rather than test
where you can actually tank it and break
it down so the next direction was
mediation and we wanted to see that okay
so if we have if a system that knows
about the driving complexity during
during driving can it effectively
intervene and it's basically can the
system it alert the user at a point so
that they can focus back on driving if
they're having a phone conversation
during during driving
okay so there are three things that we
had looked at so we had looked at
providing a very general message about
okay pay attention and then the other
one is that there is a roadblock coming
up you need to start paying attention
the second one is that we would put the
call on hold or we would call continue
and see how people would just basically
taper off by themselves and the timing
of this intervention so would we enter
people and right in the middle or should
we wait until they reach some kind of a
break point let them finish that
sentence
and what we found is that interventions
that had more explicit messages that
told people exactly what to expect so
those were more effective which makes a
lot of sense but we were worried about
the part that load that it might put on
people when they're trying to process
that this was traded off by a slowing
down in the conversation so people would
actually slow down in their conversation
when they would get these alerts not so
surprisingly drivers preferred the
intervention because it directly
impacted them the colors on the other
end they really didn't have any
awareness or they didn't really care all
that much though they were drivers
themselves and it basically means that
we need to educate people on the danger
of driving and conversing so I know that
I don't have time but I'm going to
quickly talk about this one because the
last result where the caller's don't
have really they didn't seem to think
that the intervention was useful because
the call was put on hold this is where
we thought about okay let's share some
information with the drivers with the
colors I'm sorry and see how they
regulate the conversation and we found
that the callers actually if you shared
growth sounds with the callers during
the conversation they would actually
regulate the conversation they would
speak in shorter sentences and they
would take on the load of conversation
on themselves more I am gonna skip this
part because I know that I'm over time
I'm gonna just quickly leave you with
this rather dense slide and let's leave
it up
I kept it there because I thought that
it would be good for the discussion if
people are able to read it but I think
that we'll just stop here I mean I hope
you don't mind we're gonna stop here
just because I would like to get some
feedback from the audience and you know
we will kind of yeah so that is the goal
yeah so please go ahead and start
writing and putting up those and
John will walk around and try give
mission I see that Don has his hands up
so yes we're now in the discussion phase
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead and do
discussions and then about a minute or
two before I have you go put up your
slide before now yeah go go Don Oh
microphone we need the microphone yeah
Don Norman what I'm curious about is the
timing so in the first study you talked
about in the cellphone and there's a
warning as you know at one hundred at
sixty miles an hour in one second you go
ninety feet so did you actually what I'd
like to see is a simulator study where
some unexpected event happens how much
time does it take people to be able to
start their response and or we could do
this even in where you have an expected
response and you alert them and then I
still want to know how many seconds it
takes them before they could actually
respond have you done that study so we
haven't done that study per se but the
way that we set up the alerts so I mean
we had told people that you're gonna
drive in 50 miles an hour so that's
where we had constrainted that you can
drive hundred miles the other one is
that we provided the alerts within with
enough time so that if they listen to it
and they they hit the brake pillow they
should be able to stop in time what we
saw was a lot of kind of like slamming
down on the brakes because one is that
it's a simulator study so they are
really not worried about really killing
people but no one also wants to kill
someone in a simulator but there was a
lot of slamming down we didn't see a lot
of kind of like slowly pacing down but
one thing we did see is that people in
general they would drive below the speed
limit because they knew that they were
engaging in the secondary task and so
they would almost kind of like correct
themselves ahead of time and they would
drive slower so that they would be able
to react but I think that that that's a
great point about kind of like figuring
on what is the safe stopping distance
and all of that but I believe there have
been other stuff
that has looked at that yeah so I'm a
little curious about the intervention
the intervention that you described and
that was you would put the call on hold
correct have you noticed that people
would perhaps react differently to being
placed on hold where all of their
cognitive attention would go towards
what just happened and completely leave
the roadway was there any adverse effect
so it was interesting because we thought
that the call on hold would be I mean
one is that it is daring it did give you
a message at the beginning the call is
being put on hold and so this is
something that both the color and the
driver could hear so for the driver it
made a bit more sense because they were
in that environment they could see what
was coming up and so they could easily
kind of like understand what what the
reasoning was for the color on the other
end they had no clue and so they would
suddenly abruptly be cut off and then
the driver would start speaking again
and then they and so for them it was
actually not a super comfortable
experience but yes when we didn't put
the call on hold we did find that
halfway through the conversation the
driver would stop and say that wait I
need to take care of this and so I mean
maybe there are better ways of smoothing
people into that whole situation but at
that point we just wanted to see that
okay let's see what happens we just turn
up the coat well entirely and one thing
before I go to the next person is you
know as you're thinking of the ideas
that you know I'm hoping that shams ease
talk generate some ideas for maybe some
other projects or other things that you
can do in the driving simulator please
write them down and post it up okay
there was another question on this yeah
so this is this related to two Don's
coming away it's it's switch cost and in
part it seems like in I mean there's
always the question about the
environment in which they're set so they
actually are set to be preparing
themselves to switch between tasks right
and part of the challenge for actual
drivers is that they don't do that right
so they're not engaged in the phone
conversation with the question in mind
okay I'm monitoring too
tasks on an ongoing basis so there they
may be in a different cognitive state
with a task that has characterized that
way the most relevant and this is the
study that I did skip over is let's see
so this was a study where we're in a
semi autonomous scenario and so we were
looking at what happens when we provide
alerts to people way ahead of time right
now I believe tesla gives you an alert
Eric I not in turn is your house okay so
so what we wanted to see is that let's
add another alert say like 30 seconds
before and there was literature that
shows that it was about 22 seconds and
just to be on the safe side that 30
seconds before we will start alerting
you that's there's something coming up
on the road and these were for all
credited things that are gonna happen
this is not for situations where someone
suddenly runs onto the road so we kind
of constrained us that way but we wanted
to see that we start from 30 seconds and
we tested with two different types of
alerts one was kind of like a bursty
alert where before 30 seconds and then
at 15 seconds and then at 10 seconds and
then you get your Tesla style alert then
the other one was kind of like you get
this increasing pulse so it starts it
starts pinging you or starts like this
this pulse at 30 second then it
gradually increases in in its pulse rate
and in its intensity and we found that
people were reacting better to the to
the the increasing frequency and they
were able to actually leave their tests
that they were doing at a reasonable
State because otherwise they're just
dropping their phone and there's
immediately switching over here they
were able to smooth out of their test
and at the same time via themselves
prepared for taking over so maybe in a
semi of Nova's vehicle it makes sense to
not just have one alert but multiple
answer your question so - if you can
have so one thing is just practically
whether or not you can get the relevant
information but the other thing is just
the cognitive state one of the
challenges for the drivers is that
they're not in a state where they are
saying oh okay let me attend see when
the alert comes then see when I got a
response so it's a complicated thing to
do in a simulator but having them in a
state which is typical of what the
drivers state is
other than one in which they are
experimental set to respond
differentially to those that's that's a
hard task but it's so that's one of the
reasons why similar to generate
generalizing from similar interest
studies to the real world is always
difficult and of course we have
constraints around how much we can
actually test out especially at
Microsoft I mean we we haven't been able
to move beyond the simulators I think
for me one of the questions is I think
we have very different driving scenarios
people go in for hours on the motorway
versus the city and I think what we have
done in research over the last years is
very often not making very clear
distinctions noting some of those
automation tasks are really easy on the
on the motorway and you can and I think
also looking at the timings we have we
have very often these running it ten
minutes running it 15 minutes or nothing
this is typically not giving you the
problematic stages so usually it's after
if you look at statistics it's after
hours of driving and nothing so my
question is if we do sort of these
academic exercises we publish how much
they really translate into sort of the
transformation of how we really can use
the car so my question is really should
we not rather really look at what are
the things which are difficult and
basically there's a lot of hand over
things like this which are tricky and
and my question is maybe more useful to
think what are the things we can
automate be sort of the motorway with
additional infrastructure and the things
we can not automate and not try to mix
them at least for the near future okay
great I'm gonna ask Angie to go ahead
and get set up for the next one is there
any other comments if Albert's question
I'm sorry so I think that's really a
very very important point and I mean I
as an interruption or a tension
researcher I always worry about kind of
like trying to generalize too much from
simulator studies but I think that this
is a great discussion point for this
group here is thinking about how can we
design these studies or how can we move
them move the knowledge forward if we're
also it's not viable to think that many
of these things that we can do out or
test out on the road so what is kind of
like can we determine ahead of time okay
these are the things that we are
not going to be able to automate and
these are the things where we see some
opportunities and in my later talk today
we'll talk a little bit about that but
yes I think that one of the things that
I do want to make kind of like very
clear is that our goal first and
foremost is the grabbing safety right I
think I think it's a fair point to
discuss how we can design these kinds of
studies I know for sure that there are
some studies that look at mind-wandering
that happens when people started to get
boring during when they're driving and
so in those cases if you actually
strategically place some tasks that
makes people more alert I mean that's
the reason why we listen to music or
listen to news when they're driving for
a long time and no one else is in the
car who's who can keep me alert but I
think that that's also a fair discussion
point because I really don't have an
answer for that either
well thank you Shamsi thank you very
much so please put up your ideas just
some couple of things well you know we
talked about switch costs you know the
switching of the cost associated with
attending to the road to attending to
other things so this idea of task
switching might actually generate some
ideas actually capturing the appropriate
cognitive state as well as the value of
capturing information in a simulator
versus the on-road and what is the
difficulty about looking at you know
trying to get some information on safety
in that respect and then also looking at
what we can and cannot automate so maybe
that might help generate some ideas and
I bring it to my next speaker and Joo
Koon so you have 10 minutes go ahead yes
your your oh good
Thank You Linda okay so um what I wanted
to talk about today is an overview of
where we stand I was really curious if
if I could figure out what the state of
the art is and I know we know from Eric
what the state of the art is for him and
then just you know what exactly do we
have on the roads today and what is the
outlook sorry I wanted to start with
this really nice figure from paper by
Stephens of his colleagues from this
year's CAI where they compare what
today's travel to work and back looks
like to perhaps what it might look like
say 25 years from today if we have
decent automation in place for vehicles
so what you see at the top of the figure
is the distribution of time for today
right so you have breakfast at home then
you travel to work and you do your work
9:00 to 5:00 travel home relaxed dinner
and so forth and what we might be able
to do if we have better vehicles that
allow us some automations and freedom in
the vehicles this is the vision right so
perhaps I don't know are we gonna have
breakfast in the car I'm not convinced
but you know you might be able to eat
you might be able to do some work in the
vehicle and then both going to work and
perhaps traveling back you might be able
to relax this is going to come up later
in one of our in our work as well and I
wanted to point out a couple things look
at the travel time for example right the
travel time is extended because you feel
so comfortable in your new vehicle
that's automated that you're willing to
travel further from from work right so
you're willing to move further away
notice the fact that work has extended
right so we have more time for work this
is by the way a tricky point this came
up in various conversations throughout
this this faculty summit is that a good
thing where is that a bad thing is this
a way that we're gonna try to make work
creep into people's lives more and more
and more and take advantage of them or
is this you know someone said I would
like to finish my kite paper that's our
perspective right give me some more time
so I can write back hi paper and so
that's a valid that's a concern however
overall do you notice that
the vision is that the total time
including travel and work is shorter
right so the this person in this
scenario leaves at 8:30 comes back at
5:30 but leaves at 8:30 in his back
having relaxed by 5:00 p.m. right so
even though they worked more they
actually could the total time spent is
less so we can definitely discuss how
exactly this works out and what exactly
those distributions are but there is
some interesting hopes and interesting.i
potentials oh this is the state of the
art though right it's at least from my
perspective so this is me sitting on a
bus with or it and writing a workshop
proposal and so really what what my what
I perceived to be the state of the art
is that really I'm gonna take my laptop
then it's gonna be on my lap and and I'm
going to work oh I did find one
interesting what I think is the state of
the art so this is an uber commercial
and maybe I can play it yeah there goes
so this is a commercial for a upper you
know higher end service sorry and this
is what they're saying look you can sit
in the back of the car is going to be
very comfortable and what exactly are
you going to be doing calling there's
going to be an iPad what do you call it
a tablet right in a computer and these
are the things that you're going to be
working on it's comfortable and
nevertheless status sort of the state of
the act of what we can expect to be
doing I want to say that John Lee
pointed out to me done and one of these
frames there were two people sitting
next to each other it was supposed to be
showing two different cars but that's
also an interesting question of I think
privacy came up in one of the comments
when we went around the room you know if
you do travel with other people even if
it's comfortable and you're working how
does how does privacy play into this and
here's another promotional picture for
uber so Martha Stewart promotes uber and
this is you know the vision from Martha
Stewart's perspective and I really like
this photo for a couple of different
reasons one is that it shows her doing
things that you're not doing right now
in the car and actually cannot do in the
car so you know Martha Stewart is
preparing some sort of a very fancy
looking some sweets right there for your
fee
she looking and she's just this is what
she does anyway she makes us feel kind
of bad about how we can't do this so
easily but true the truth is you were
not gonna do this in the car it's gonna
be bouncy and bumpy and you know it's
not really but again think of the let's
think about what we could be doing in
the future that's what I think is it
interesting about this there is also a
printer and that actually is starting to
be something you know you could sort of
see something like that so what I'm what
i like about this photo is that it
encourages me to think about things that
it we're not currently doing not just
like that commercial before where you're
you know here you are on the laptop but
what other interesting things might
there be that could be possible to do
and I think that's we're thinking about
and then worth pointed out to me that
Martha's looking at the window it's
probably a feature that was supposed to
be artistic but or its point is that a
lot of us motion sing right and the only
way we can handle working in the car is
to frequently look out the window so
again as we think about automated
vehicles this is something that we
should consider I really like this paper
to Boston plinging who was Albert's PhD
student and a couple of colleagues
wanted to see what people are interested
in doing in the automated vehicles but
the part that I'm showing here is what
people are currently say they are doing
in automated or in manually driven
vehicles so this is a three hundred
participants who completed a survey and
when they drive they call and text in a
pretty large numbers from the paper I
can't quite tell I'll have to ask
question what it means the text in this
context do they mean I'm stopped at the
red light and I'm texting or do they
mean something else do they mean voice
interfaces but nevertheless these are
the types of tasks that they're
undertaking right now and passengers do
all kinds of other things as well
including email including whatever they
call office tasks right so I think it's
really interesting because this does
capture something about what people are
doing right now and this is going to be
something that we'll talk more about
from our own view of this on through
this this nsf-funded project the next
mobile office so the five of us and you
can you can talked about talk to us
about this project throughout the day
but the vision that we have is something
like this I was just talking to Yvonne
about the our need for the next version
of hololens but you know what if you
were that driver and your car can take
over for some amount of time maybe it's
five minutes ten minutes whatever it is
you know how could we support you in
doing work beyond having a laptop on
your on your lap and we think that as
far as the human machine interaction is
concerned
augmented reality speech interaction and
tangible interfaces might be the way to
go so I'm showing augmented reality here
this is one of Word students really nice
work here showing this and then some
sort of a speech interaction right and
some tangible interface some something
physical but probably small we don't
necessarily think that a laptop is
something that's all that great for this
for multiple reasons one is that you
have to look down but the other ISM
really curious what everybody thinks
about how long you know these handovers
are gonna be interesting cars will
eventually say look it's your turn and
it's actually probably going to be often
right and the handover will have to
happen and that's probably going to be
short one major manufacturer last year
was promoting a vehicle that isn't quite
doing this right now but they said fully
taking ends off to the wheel we're gonna
take over driving and the time they give
you to come back is ten seconds and I
don't think you can stow your laptop in
10 seconds safely right so so I think
this is interesting to think about and I
think it's really important we talked
about safety we it's critical this hand
over all happen and then whatever is
there to support your work at the very
least has to get out of the way and
ideally actually can support you in
driving so if you do have augmented
reality that can be something that that
can help with when navigation for
example or helping you with with finding
you know street signs and so forth I
wanted to quickly put up a couple of
things that I think would be interesting
these transitions this is work with
shawnzy and actually led by Christian
Johnson who was a Duncan squeezie
student
and his colleague Stella Stella donker
and the idea here is the following the
transitions between the non-driving task
and the driving tasks are not just
simply we're doing one and then we're
doing the other and we're coming back
but rather there are stages so what the
stages are we can argue about that the
details of that right but you will be
going through some stages in terms of
handing back and forth and importantly
there's gonna be interleaving meaning
that while you're doing the or
non-driving task and you're starting to
do your driving task you might come back
to the non driving task and go back and
forth and this is a safety concern right
this is something that has to be
designed properly so that for example
the actual physical transfer of control
doesn't happen you know after suspending
the non driving task right so you might
not have suspended the nine driving task
you might still be engaged in that non
driving task even after you're driving
this diagram and then I have two more
slides on that so it's really quick now
I knew it was not gonna run over in time
because you know she won't want me one
paper that I thought was really very
interesting is this paper by Magnuson
and Pope and they talked about it's a
review of biomechanics in and how in
working postures and one really
interesting thing about this to me was
that they found drivers with lower back
pain right and especially if the drive
is long and there's lots of vibration as
well as musculoskeletal problems neck
shoulder arm especially if your arms are
say not supported and what we're talking
about thing back to that first slide
extended drives because you're so happy
that your car can drive itself but there
is this concern that since you're
driving longer now you're introducing
issues that could hurt you physically
right so I think that this is one of
those things that we really need to be
concerned about as far as we as our
design so to wrap up today we have
simple tasks right I think the state of
the art we can we can argue is that so
the vast majority of us the best we can
hope for is that we'll be on our laptop
or some sort of a pad and we have high
hopes for tomorrow but as we do that
as we look at that tomorrow we should
really look at motion sickness we should
look at privacy and but how do you
become partners in privacy as John I
think really nice to put it and then
safety I think it's really interesting
to look at this interleaving between
tasks and then economics we must worry
about that so great thank you Andrew so
we're gonna go ahead and go into the
discussion portion I'm gonna ask our
speaker to repeat the question once you
hear it and I will now open it up for
comments a discussion jim Dinkelman for
Microsoft Research are you aware of
research that that that approaches a
problem by sense and the cognitive load
that each of our senses require so for
instance listening is very easy and very
low cognitive when we've been doing that
for decades in the car we've been
multitasking listening we've started to
talk and that's a little bit more of a
cognitive load once I get into visual
and touch actions in the car are you
aware and aware of any research that
there is that is that relevant thinking
along that dimension I think you're
you're hitting it right on the head I
think a lot of us have been thinking
about that and I think Shawn's in fact
just mentioned that it in her in her
presentation as well so as far as
cognitive load and the mall and and Eric
actually mentioned this as well right so
in terms of multiple resource theory I
think a lot of us do you think that this
is a this is exactly how you should look
at it and and hope to I have to do a
correction this is not exactly a you
should look at it there's been a huge
amount of research on this and actually
Alan Baddeley published a paper like a
century ago in which he had people
driving and they listened to the radio
station playing and say the news
broadcast or they're listening to a
radio station with people playing
football look this is an England so it's
soccer and listening to the soccer game
was really wrecked the driving
performance because it's a visual task
right they're listening to a visual
thing so they're listening auditorily so
the point is there's a lot of literature
and it's a bit more complex and
one sensory modality versus another I
would like to add something to Don's
point which was interesting because when
we had designed our initial study about
giving the road directions the first one
that I had to describe where people were
trying to either recall information or
give Road directions and Eric and I
hypothesized that the road Direction
path would be much more it would
conflict much more for driving because
that is also visual I mean at least when
I give Road directions to someone I
visually think about the roads and it is
complex because I believe just the fact
that people are breaking it down made it
somehow cognitively more manageable
where when they were trying to recall
information maybe they're also trying to
visualize that when did I last take gas
in my car well I have to visualize that
when did I last go to Costco or wherever
or so I think that it is not as simple
it's just having the speech or listening
as soon as you start visualizing it and
as you mentioned soccer is a visual
thing to think about I mean Eric has
examples about visualizing an airport
what what is the thing called the
display board sorry of the actual
schedule screen until someone shouted
stop
as I said visiting Irvine at the giving
it talk down at Irvine UC Irvine and all
the grad students shouted Spoleto at
dinner and it's like the this visual UI
had evaporated and I see through the
windshield again pretty surprised all
the professors in front of us stopped
their car quickly and with it taking
them out so so the cut chomp she's
coming it even beyond football versus
you have to be cautious done because the
the football versus the news reports and
the music is I think unfortunately maybe
there's some marginals there some over
but it's too high level of me more
details the fact that we found and it's
just one study we did that memory tasks
recalling when you did an oil change he
wouldn't lose their try
the road and being trouble with a memory
task we don't know what how much what
combination of visual reminder meant
remembering what it was getting in the
way of their being able to navigate and
be aware and sense with their with that
situation but um it suggests the theory
we came up with it is in the paper
getting into this into the detailed
structure of how cognition works when it
comes to giving directions versus
remembering oil changes Wow could you
really put stuff on the on the stack and
push and pop the stack about directions
with memory when you need to attend and
still remain alert and you can't do that
with this gigantic call we were waiting
for the answer to come back about the
oil change so I really want to suggest
to this community of folks interested in
this that would be great to get into the
right level of detail and then to
abstract from that versus start with
high-level so so I really okay don't go
ahead I just wanted to pick up you're
talking about basically current day
activities and and you talked about like
bastian survey and so what do I can't
help notice I owe you CL the offices in
central London but we live like 50 miles
away towards Cambridge and so commuting
on a train going into the office and
just you can't have a noticed look when
you get onto a busy commuter train just
the patterns of people's natural
behavior right and I think one of these
things is to start understanding the way
people work and want to work and so
picking up on what we saw a Gloria
Mark's work on the opening down
Wednesday the types of work that people
do when it's very clear in the morning
people are getting their head down and
doing focused work there's a lot of
activity you can hear it with the
fingers tapping people preparing slides
writing emails in the evening coming
home there's no work there are no
laptops out if there is a laptop out if
somebody watching a movie or play a game
on their phone there's very little
activities it's kind of funny just to
understand I think one of things without
understanding more about the types of
activities people doing when how that
fits into their daily schedule is
I'm getting kicked off but I totally
agree and one thing that we're gonna
hear soon about is what is it that
people would like to do and I think that
goes along with and then I think it's
really important what what everybody's
saying right including Derrick is what
is it that tech can provide and I think
that there's this push and pull of you
know let's not design things that people
don't want but also let's kind of inform
people's desires with what is possible
and that includes you know cognition as
well as as well as detect that that
provides that even keep the interaction
every day know and totally agree and
told yeah so maybe one last question or
last comment okay so my last question
about privacy so omission about this
year right writer about privacy but also
wondering what do you think about the
privacy when selling cars are collecting
all the different kind of similar data
because it might be a privacy violation
not just for the driver the passenger
but also for the other cars and
pedestrians I I think this is a really
complex question and and I don't know
perhaps at some point John might be a
better person to answer that but yeah
I'm aware of the fact that it's a
complex question and that's the
expensive but I don't know if you wanted
to just to remind people who have had
these great comments that were just
shared write them down and post them up
yes thank you I was just going to remind
people to do the same thing so just like
a couple of comments that I've heard I
just want to summarize real quickly
privacy issues where something that we
didn't talk about earlier but it'd be
great to you know maybe capture some of
that the user interface and what type of
you know system and how it should look
is actually really important and then
what are people actually really
interested in doing and then maybe
actually looking at some of the micro
levels and trying to understand some of
the details out of things that people
actually want to do in their cars and
then taking a look at that in the
context of the large picture there's a
wire right here
so it is my pleasure to introduce our
next speakers which is oriT and Rafaela
and i'm gonna take a second let's clap
for Andrew first thank you Andrew okay
go ahead already hear me
is it on can you hear me okay great
thank you this is great to join the
discussion now that we're starting to
think about attention productivity with
concrete findings from a preliminary
study of what people want to do in a car
and what people hope to do in the car so
this is work that I'm conducting as part
of the NSF funded research together with
or a team I will present this together
with Rafael Azul Rafaela is joining us
online
Rafaella yes hi everybody great I'm a
professor of computer science at
Wellesley and this is a very
interdisciplinary perspective of our
work so I'm going to start ok so I'm
going to start by thinking about our
methodology so one of the goal for NSF
funded research is to identify the needs
of commuting workers and managers and we
have three different stages for not
necessarily linear for our methodology
the first one is to study existing data
specifically we're looking into the
American time use a survey refinery team
John and his team are analyzing this
data and looking for trends that relate
to commuting with workers and managers
we're conducting a new large-scale time
usage well-being study in order to
understand what users are currently
doing drivers are currently doing in the
car and what they're hoping to do in the
car and we're planning to follow up with
a series of in-depth ethnographic
studies today our focus will be on the
large-scale study and the preliminary
findings from this study so here we see
a snippet from that's not good
and okay so here we see a snippet from
our study this is a new survey that we
designed that is based on the executive
time usage study that Rafael and her
team and been using on an international
group of executives what we ask our
participants to do we ask them to enter
a full agenda of a representative work
day and we ask them to enter all of
their activities from the time that they
wake up to the time that they go to
sleep that lasts more than 15 minutes
so the granularity that we get is
activities personal activities work
activities some qualitative data and we
modify this questionnaire to give a
small granularity around commuting
specifically were interested in
multitasking and commuting what non
driving tasks users are currently doing
what non driving tasks users are
interested in doing we also added some
questions to this study in order to kind
of measure the appeal of different
alternative to commuting so what will
people do if they don't have to commute
what will people do if they commute in a
self-driving car and we looked at
morning versus evening commute
separately so we deployed this
preliminary and these are the results
that I'll present today with a
Mechanical Turk sample so this is a
sample of 220 people 40% female we got a
variety of backgrounds we had of 148
people that reported to be commuters out
of these commuters 126 reported to be
driving themselves during the commute
and for these commuters the mean commute
time was 60 minutes daily so this is the
sample that we're working with Rafael
are you back
okay and Rafael are you back Rafael are
you online this will be a good time to
get her okay okay so I'll just kind of
keep going so looking at the general
time share of activity throughout the
day we see that commuting is just under
8% for this sample not surprisingly we
see that commuting activities are
concentrated in the morning and in the
afternoon and that their inter living
together with personal and with work
activities we did find out more
commuting is associated with less time
spent in personal activities and that
shows us that commuting is really
substituting for personal time and that
45% of our commuters Rafael are you back
Rafael ah just in time
okay so I'm just saying that 45% of our
commuters associate commuting with
negative feelings and specifically with
tiredness and stress so is this general
overview as I mentioned what we were
really interested especially within the
context of the last today's discussion
on productivity is what people are
currently doing in the car and when we
ask what people are currently doing in
the car we talk beyond driving so what
are the non driving things that people
are currently doing and what are the non
driving tasks that commuters will be
interested or desire to do in a
self-driving car so I'll escort fella to
take us through our finding what do
people do while commuting yeah and in
light of what I just said it's not
surprising that a lot of what people do
while commuting relates to their
personal time and even a sense telling
us that commute is a way through which
people take back that personal time that
is that is lost going or coming back
from work what
is really interesting and what I think
we are trying to get out with this data
is that there are strong differences
between managers and non managers which
suggests that in part what you do while
you are commuting depends on your
socioeconomic status it depends on your
type of job for example managers might
be more interested or more needing to do
interactive work which can be done in a
car now
the second benefit going to the type of
activities that people do while
commuting this time use survey one of
the you know the second benefit that it
provides is that a lot it allows you to
go deep into the secondary activities
and you know here I would say it's not
surprising it's nevertheless very scary
to see that a lot of the secondary
activities work secretary activities
that are happening inside the car are
things that are probably not very safe
at the moment for example reading emails
or replying to emails which are in the
in the words of the speaker before us
active types of tasks there is a fair
amount of passive cognitively perhaps
less demanding thinking and reflecting
done require so much multitasking
profile I just for this audience I would
like to point out even though these are
the things that we found less but people
are programming and analyzing data in
the car yeah and you don't see some of
the audience but some of the audience is
kind of shaking the hand in disbelief
yeah I'm not in the city when I when I
travel yes one of the things that we
really are trying to push with this kind
of research is to try and think about
the experience in commuting as part of
the whole working activity and so this
is one you know going to what what
people do right after him before the
commute or the differences between
morning and evening I'm not gonna go in
detail in this but the answer is we do
find that there are different patterns
of activities as you would
and I think it's important to understand
how commuting fits with the rest of the
day and also thinking about what people
can shift in an autonomous vehicle when
when the technology is ready so for
example much more thinking replying to
every time two emails in the morning
much less of that in the people
commuting my fella just one second I'll
jump to this slide I was just showing
the general graph that shows that if if
people can drive a self-driving vehicle
then we see that their interest in
working is increasing compared to the
current commute so they still mostly
they're still mostly interested in doing
personal stuff while in the car but they
have an increasing interest both for
workers and for managers to do work in a
self-driving car and now I'm moving to
this slide with a specific differences
that you can describe yeah you ask
people what they want to do and they
answer to you they just want to do more
emails and so it's I think you know and
less thinking and reflecting if you
notice on the right so this I think
poses some interesting questions for the
technology development and in the sense
that you know one question that we have
as a team is for example whether new
technologies should try to preserve
personal time or increased work whether
there are ways for the technology to
support a transition from and to
personal time and also within working
activities whether we should try and
increase the efficiency of what people
are currently doing and demanding to do
for example emails or if there is be an
opportunity to develop technologies that
can help protect more thinking and
reflecting right under to say that we
are thinking of this in terms of also
collecting more data and finding ways to
you know we really think it will be
important to explore these questions in
the other samples of knowledge or
to really pin down the type of
correlations that we are finding here
and I'll pass it on to elite who will
discuss me
Pacific technology right so kind of
specifically we are interested in
gathering more data and as a Ravello
implied we think that what you do
forward the social economic status does
matter in terms of what you want to do
in the car so specifically we would like
to focus on knowledge workers which
bring us here to Microsoft we hope to
collect more data with a large sample of
people that are driving the car people
that perhaps are driven for example
people that commute with uber on a
regular basis people that drive in cars
that have strong automation features
like Tesla and people that use something
like the Microsoft shadow so different
modes of transportation for knowledge
workers in terms of Technology design I
want to show a quick video I know that
someone wants to help me with the video
a quick video of some of the ideation
that we're doing in our lab this is
ideation that follow up the nice sketch
that Andrew was showing thinking how can
we take the test that people want to do
the tasks that people are currently
doing in design for a simulator kind of
environment brainstorming of how this
could be done so here we're exploring
different modalities of interactions so
what if we let them rehearse
presentations and what will gesture
interaction in the car free hands will
look like what would it look like with a
little controller combination of
tangible inputs together with voice
right and how the transitions would look
like when you have to now put your
little tangibles aside and kind of go
back to driving how the kind of
windshield which we assume I have
augmented reality capabilities will
clear up to support the driving task but
at the same time will allow you to wrap
up on what you were doing because we
don't want users to kind of have this
lingering effect of still being focused
on
thank you very much I'm going to just
cut this just a little bit I want to
make sure that we're done yeah yeah I
just make sure the we have time for
Satish and also for a break so I'm just
gonna open up for just like maybe like
six minutes of questions oh hi
so just picking up on this focusing on
the commuting and just the the contrary
point is is just get rid of commuting
all right so I was at a session
conference last week and someone was
reviewing work on productivity and the
research is there showing that people
well what you're saying here is that
people don't like commuting right it
makes them feel miserable and stressed
and on the flip side when you look at
productivity people who work from home
have higher productivity gains some of
what's driving that is self selection
bias people who are more motivated and
focus can work better at home but it's
kind of an interesting idea that you
know as we move in and some of the
topics have been discussed over this
past couple of days has been around the
kind of the opportunities for the global
workforce to 50-round knowledge work to
kind of dial in and do remote work more
justice alternatives like focusing at
the moment on making the commute better
but instead do we still need the commute
when so much work is done for an
internet connection on a screen it's
actually an interesting kind of meta
comment as related to our first
deployment of the study because our
first deployment of the study was with
Mechanical Turk users who are people
that at least part of the time work from
home on what they consider to be
Mechanical Turk home still the majority
of these people were commuting to some
sort of work so even though there were
freelancing they still had a place to
commute to and come back from on a
regular basis but but I think that's
that's an interesting point to consider
I think that the reason why we focus on
managers is interesting to us because to
some extent for managers interpersonal
interactions will always be needed and
so I think you're right and I'm very
familiar with that with the study on
commuting and working from home so some
professions may be commuting one be
needed but my impression is that for
managers perhaps there will never be a
moment or two
elimination of going to work and showing
your face and see what people think Don
I think the studies that you're doing
are really important and but there's
it's it's actually again quite complex
we've been doing studies similar and
we've ended up with a three by yeah
three by three matrix
and even that's an oversimplification
because first of all the kind of vehicle
matters so we've been looking at in
theory completely driverless vehicles no
driver and therefore we configure the
interior space and we asked people to
configure it from what activity you'd
like to do and if you put people in a
bus that restricts the kinds of
activities they can do and in an
automobile with the standard parallel
seats also restricts but we've
discovered that there's a difference
between short trips which might include
commuting medium length trips which
might be an hour or more which for some
is commuting but and and long trips
which might be driving up San Diego to
San Francisco ten hours or so and then
it depends whether you're driving
whether you're alone or whether you're
where the group but there are two kinds
of groups one is a group of strangers
and the other is a group of friends and
so we discover the activities vary a lot
depending upon that and when the long
trips there was never a single activity
I need to work for the first few hours
but then I want to relax I want to watch
a movie and one etcetera etcetera and so
it's it's actually a really fascinating
topic and I think it's gonna make a
really big difference as we move forward
so thank you yes we are thinking of this
complexity there is a lot of data that
we collected and are analyzing and
didn't share it in the last ten minutes
of presentation some of it has to do
with the fact that yes you're traveling
with people and we're inquiring who are
the people that you're traveling with in
the car our focus is on the work context
rather than to travel to San Diego to LA
or San Diego to San Francisco context we
ask people explicitly to think about a
representative
workday that was the context of our
study I agree that it's important to
study all these different conditions
I also want to mention something about
the study that Andrew showed before it's
also important to study them in
different contexts so the study that
Andrew show of Bastien's work was made
mostly in Germany we're currently
planning perhaps multicultural
perspective we would like to study this
in Germany in the UK in the u.s. perhaps
with our managers in China so culture is
also one important condition for culture
as well as other aspects yes so I'm
gonna just give you one second because
that's gonna be the last comment but I
just want to say so this survey that or
it has Raphael is talking about we're
actually very open to sharing it because
we would like to get as many users to
participate in it and be able to look
these cultural differences as well as
even just geographical differences ok so
I remember when Jung Lee come to our
Institute gave our talk one of the
things he talked about is I off the road
is really dangerous and I have seen two
speakers talking about the AR they have
been in the reality yeah actually some
people may believe that once you're
looking two views in you're not doing
the eye of the road but I know as I know
that this augmented reality idea concept
has been tired decades ago by the
Detroit on a pilot and didn't work and
the number of the Vision Research have
been showing that we have two views
together you're not necessarily see both
there's a lot of change brightness or
inattentional blindness happen so that
means simply prison the two views they
may still don't see many things on road
so it's a very important that you are
thinking about in human interface
how you gonna present those information
so that they don't miss one of the newly
agree but I just want to mention that we
already have augmented reality in the
car if you drive in a car that has kind
of a heads out display you have
augmented reality on your windshield so
this is happening
and we need to make sure that this is
happening safely for supporting other
tasks beyond driving we also have to
develop and in our lab together with
Andrew and his students we're working on
that we also have to develop the
technologies to study what we're doing
and to make sure that we understand
where people are looking at when using
augmented reality for different tasks
and it's also totally agree and it's
also worth mentioning that it's ideally
truly augmenting reality so it shouldn't
be two views while you're driving right
it's not just a simple display that you
have to look to and in addition
hopefully it's actually the work part
dependent you're totally right you have
to turn it off right if you are I'm very
very sorry but we're gonna because we're
really getting close to break time cube
but we're gonna have lots opportunity to
talk and I want to make sure I really
give Satya an opportunity to do is talk
so let's tank or it for thank you very
much we're so teach you enjoy and take
it away Mike fun yes I think so
good morning again everybody and thank
Linda for this opportunity
I'm Satish I'm from Microsoft Research
India we have a lab in Bangalore which
is in the southern part of India and
today I'm going to talk about one of our
ongoing projects in the lab called hands
and I will come to what ham stands for
in a second this is joint work with my
colleagues Akshay and linker to our
research as a matter of India and a
bunch of very smart research fellows and
interns who we have working on the
project also the motivation for hams was
basically and no I don't know how many
of you have come to India or have
experienced how there's to drive on
roads in India but if you have you
quickly realize that you know you know
that there is a serious problem that we
face in that part of the world
India has probably among the highest
rate of the tech fatalities in terms of
road accidents Road Safety is a really
critical issue and that kind of became a
starting you know point for for for hams
and and when we looked at road safety
you know again given the conditions that
exist in our part of the world I am
pretty sure you know like him know I'm
also going to be dead by time driverless
cars become a reality in India but you
know so when we looked at you know road
safety we kind of
start focusing on looking at doing
things which could potentially improve
wood driving practices by focusing on
driver and driving behavior and that
really led to hams being born so hands
really stands for
right so hamster essentially stands for
harnessing automobiles for safety and
the core idea there was to use you know
technology in a way that could be easily
integrated with existing you know
vehicle populations in India and you
know use techniques which could then you
know look at you know monitoring driver
behavior in a useful way
right so when we looked at you know easy
no retrofitting an existing vehicle is
the most obvious device that you know
obviously came to light was a smartphone
because everybody obviously carries a
smartphone so the core idea behind
Hamm's is to use camera based sensors
which are available in off-the-cuff
smartphones of a shelf smartphones and
use that as a device within the vehicle
infected within the vehicle and to
monitor driver behavior which can lead
to hopefully you know more responsible
ways of driving and improving overall
driving practices in India right we also
have developed via hams techniques which
could because this involves a lot of
video processing before the hams also
allows for you know h processing so we
don't ship all the video that's recorded
you know by the camera sensor in the
vehicle you know back to cloud we
basically generate incidents so that
only relevant video snippets which are
relevant to the specific incidents you
know where something needs to be alerted
or super wise you know can be you know
processed and sent back you know back to
whoever is looking at the data so we
don't need to really use you know
expensive cloud connectivity kind of
scenarios because in India it's also a
reality that many places don't have
connectivity and so it's important that
we as you we don't take for granted you
know that you know you can be able to
ship a lot of video back to cloud for
efficient processing right we start out
with a pilot that we started in our own
office from Isis in MSR India we have
these shuttle just like you have here
which very employees back and forth from
their homes to offices so we started out
hams you know by fitting some of these
vehicles you know with these smartphone
based camera sensors and we've decoded
about 25,000 per second Umbra that's
about 15,000 miles of data you know
through this project and
as we speak now we are actually also
undertaking a pilot project in
partnership with the government of India
and I'll talk about that more in the
following slides right so this is
essentially what Hamm's does so as you
can probably imagine the smartphone is
fitted you know in you know inside the
vehicle and it has two cameras operating
so we operate both cameras at the same
time so the front camera of the
smartphone is and she looks in into the
car and monitors a driver state the back
camera which is on the back of the
smartphone looks out of the car and
looks at you know what's the driving
environment and of course using other
you know inputs like the GPS and the
other sensors which are available we are
able to triangulate and get inputs to
get a sense of driving context and
within that context look at driver
behavior and and and hopefully you know
have interventions which can make a
better driving practices so these are
some of the detectors that we built
within Hamm's we've looked at distracted
driving and in India it's a very common
problem although states do disallow cell
phone use while driving it's it's fairly
common to have people talking on cell
phones so we build records which can
actually detect you know cell phone
usage while driving we build detectors
that can look at you know fatigue
indicators such as yawning and by
blinking and we've also built our
detectors which can look at you know
gaze tracking so that's the driver and
this is again extremely common in India
culturally people do not you know have a
culture of really being safe while you
know approaching intersections and
things of that are they looking at you
know mirrors
you know before they're supposed to take
a left or right turn those are also
things that we want to kind of look at
you know using hands this is the driving
context which is done by the camera
which is on the back of the phone
looking out and using inputs from the
onboard diagnostic device which are
approved into the cars we can look at
things like speed and acceleration data
and and translate that with with the
environment outside so look at things
like ranging and tailgating using
positional kind of data that we get from
the outside environment and also in
provide inputs where I have
in terms of CF diving practices right so
with that kind of context setting when
we looked at scenarios in which we could
apply Hamm so a few of them kind of came
to light we could look at you know
driver training in India there are these
driving schools which train you know the
likes of the ubers you know and Ola
which is the lipstick wallet in India
you know these drivers go to these
driving schools and get certified and
using that certification they're able to
basically get job opportunities in other
companies like uber so that's one one
application that obvious is word for
hams we also got a lot of interest from
companies trucking companies as well as
ride-sharing companies in terms of fleet
monitoring because they were interested
in making sure that you know they get a
drivers who drive safely and therefore
obviously there was in person hands and
they're having couple of conversations
with some of these companies on that but
really the the scenario that we've now
focused on to start with is what is
called as license testing driver license
testing this is a project that we're
doing with the Government of India and
the Ministry of Road Transport and
highways so this really involves you
know monitoring the driver as he or she
is taking a driving test right so this
is the equivalent of the DMV as its I
think now in the US so people go to this
entity call RTO and they take a driving
test and today the situation in India
you know on licence testing is
completely broken there are statistics
again I don't know how many of you in
India but the the manual process that is
used in in the driver testing scenario
is is prone it's slow and tedious of
course it's prone to corruption and
other such issues and there are data
points you know which which are as
shocking as something like this that you
know more than half the people in India
apparently you have got driver's
licenses even without taking a test and
there are multiple reasons for for the
scenario because you know the system is
completely you know one of you know non
technology driven and it's process so
there is an opportunity that we see
where we can bring automation via a kind
of Hamm's based intervention to make the
driving driver testing process
transparent efficient you know and
obviously motor are too you know for all
so that's that's the core
right now effort with hands so what we
aim to achieve with automated driver
license testing in this case what we do
is basically we don't have someone
physically I'm wondering the driver as a
person but we have the smartphone and
using Habs hams inside the smartphone in
the vehicle we look at a scenario where
we can both increase the coverage of the
driving test parameters you can
obviously reduce cost and most
importantly make the whole process of
issuing a driver license clean and
corruption free which is a huge issue in
India it's this one hamsters so when the
sir person wants to take a driving test
you know the smartphone is fitted inside
the car and you know using very minimal
track instrumentation which is you know
that's the typical you know driving test
that a person takes in in the DMV
equivalent there and using no very very
minimal instrumentation we can basically
retrofit the this technology into that
environment and and make sure that you
know we bring about improvements and
productivity increases in the driving
test scenarios in India right so what we
also achieve to hams
is that currently this is the sample of
the parameters that are tested and I
know it's a nice yard but you know there
are about 20 parameters that are
supposed to be tested you know each
driving test before issuing someone
impervious license and what currently
happens is although that includes things
like you know mirror scanning and things
of that for today's someone sitting next
to the driver you know inside the car
it's impossible for that person you know
look at whether the person scan the
mirror before he or she took a left to
right and so even if someone present
today the current system is unable to
actually do a good job of the parameter
that I suppose we tested as part of
driving license test but with hams and
with the detectors know that we are
hopefully being a bringing into the play
we can actually increase the you know
overall efficiency of the system by you
know because of you know doing things
like they study etcetera so it makes for
you know obviously simple and low-cost
processes but also increased coverage
and well tested and same drivers who
hopefully promote you know better
driving practices on the road right so
this is a simple video I mean this is a
simulation that we did as we as we
desire testing of what really hamsters
and it will give you probably an idea of
of what we are trying to achieve you
know in the scenario we can play the
video
so there's a way to work but I can
quickly I mean as the person gets into
the car you know the smartphone
basically identifies the face and you
know make sure that the person is taking
it is exactly the person bindiya is also
a lot of issues where you know people
someone fills out the form for a driving
license and someone else take the space
there are also cannabis easily solve
that showing whether the driver is
looking straight or at the left or right
Meadows so the left screen basically
detects the outside environment and the
right screen detects you know what's
happening at the driver stage score at
the bottom right which is updated each
time a violation is detected the driver
is approaching a left turn he looks
straight while performing the turn
without scanning the mirrors as he
should have Hamm's detects that the
driver is rapidly approaching a vehicle
directly in front there is there is an
obstacle the driver approached the
obstacle at a high speed and then braked
sharply he then shifted lanes to the
right without scanning the mirrors
Hamm's detects various tagged locations
along the track in this case it detects
a pedestrian crossing here
the driver brakes abruptly and scans the
scene but only two is left before
proceeding
so interest of time I won't read the
whole video but you get a general idea I
hope and this is how basically it is
yeah yeah that's not be as one yeah so
so yeah so this is what we're doing
right now and as we speak as I said you
know we're doing this pilot with one of
the states in India and then in the
northern part of India called Oregon and
the the arteria rich is equal to the DMV
is now actually testing HAMP's to be
deployed you know at that facility and
we are pretty hopeful that you know in
in about a month's time mid-august time
we'll actually have a ham space solution
actually issuing out you know automated
driver licenses in India very soon so we
hope to kind of you know we're also
working with other government entities
there is a organization called CIRT
which is a central engine of Road
Transport which does you know technology
recommendations for various DMV
equivalent in India to adopt technology
so we are working with them to you know
validate HAMP's you know as part of
their recommendations so hopefully you
know we are we are hopeful that you know
in the coming months and years we will
have automated you know driver license
testing in India becoming a reality
which will hopefully promote safer
driving practices and hopefully less
fatalities caused because of all
accidents thank you Satish thank you you
know given that it's 10:45 and we
actually have to get notes I'm gonna ask
I'm gonna change this around a little
bit I'm gonna apologize to Satish
that we're gonna wait for questions
until afterwards what I'd like the group
to do right before they go out to get
coffee right now is to all everybody
right now take a sheet of paper because
I know some not everybody is writing
something down take a sheet of paper
write something down and Plast it up
there and then go get coffee while we
look at what we really
so teach I can I'm really so Eric
mentioned this too right the the idea
that you have how do we affect policy so
how did you do it because it's not
simply developing the software it's um
getting someone to accept it to make it
an official thing yeah so one of the
things that we started doing was we've
worked with one of the largest car
companies in India on this because they
showed interest and it so happens that
you know that company has a joint
venture with the government of India you
know for setting up a driver training
Research Institute which promotes safe
driving practices so we start out with
that pilot and through that we got
connected to the Ministry of Road
Transport and we met the minister in
charge of this and he was pretty excited
about whole thing and he said let's do a
pilot you know and then see whether it
works and that's how things got more dia
so yeah I agree with you it's a tough
job to teach around the replies